also meine kernthese ist meine aussage
ist die politik kann nicht rechnen sie
will nicht rechnen wenn sie unternehmer
sind haben sie eine bilanz da schauen
sie was auf der aktivseite also autobahn
infrastruktur nämlich ist unser
passivseite schulden was habe ich auch
für eigenkapital und die politik hatten
zwei jahre lang erzählt schwarze null
große leistung in wahrheit war es keine
große leistung sondern sich einfach nur
zinsersparnis gehabt und der
steuereinnahmen ich gebe ihnen eine zahl
zahlen sind nicht kompliziert aber der
bund allein in brüssel deutschland
allein auf bundesebene hat im zeitraum
von 2009 bis 2018
380 milliarden sie sich ausgegeben und
darüber ist 140 milliarden gespart und
40 milliarden für die arbeitslosigkeit
gespart summe waren es 460 milliarden
euro die politik zusätzlich hat er uns
haben sie erzählt sie sparen von den 180
meter 60 milliarden haben 70 milliarden
schulden getilgt das stimmt und 390
milliarden ausgegeben da frage ich mich
natürlich wo das geld geblieben war auf
wie sie sich nicht in der infrastruktur
das laden das sind doch nicht im
bildungssystem naja es ist geflossen in
rente in gesundheit in alle möglichen
dinge auch in energiewende und was im
prinzip habe dann der politik die immer
sagt der denken dann die zukunft ist
aber nicht tut die politik lebt von der
hand in den mund und das ist das
kernproblem vor denen wir stehen im land
und wir werden es ja die energiewende an
schauen wir noch ein wort dazu dass ein
schönes beispiel energiewende wir haben
lange zeit hingenommen dass wir enorme
milliardenbeträge aufgewendet haben für
die energiewende wir haben seine tun ist
für einen guten zweck wenn sie sich
anschauen den co2 ausstoß deutschland
energie sind wir mit die schlechtesten
wie kann es sein dass wir milliarden
ausgeben die schlechtesten sind und dann
heißt es müssen mehr windkraft machen
was alles andere abschalten und kohle
und kernkraftwerke abzuschalten und dann
alles auf gast zu setzen was die
bundesregierung mache das auch nicht
funktioniert erinnert hat folgen das ist
es so als wenn sie in einem boot sitzen
und sie sehen dass koffer und sie
möchten gerne dass die mannschaft
schneller rudert und deshalb schlagen
sie ein leck ins boot und das ist unsere
politik und das gilt bei energiewende
das gilt auch bei rente herr scholz hat
mal gesagt sehr schön rentensystem alles
ist sicher als ihm vorgerechnet wurde im
wahlkampf das nicht so hatte ich hätte
gerne echte expertin die suchte bis
heute noch weil die fakten einfach es
gibt nicht zusammen länger leben weniger
lang arbeiten welche beiträge ungleich
renten es gibt mathematisch nicht und da
kann man nur sagen entweder kann er
nicht rechnen oder will nicht rechnen
und das gilt nicht nur für scholz das
gilt für die vorgängerregierung und das
gilt vermutlich auch für die kommende
regierung weil die politik andere wegen
gemacht vielleicht haben wir zu wenig
mathematiker bundestag ich weiß es nicht
und das ist meine kritik und darum bin
ich besorgt für die zukunft dieses
landes was der doktor stellte anspricht
sind die sogenannten politischen
begehrlichkeiten und ich habe bereits im
ersten semester politikwissenschaften
gelernt dass gute politik vor allen
dingen darin besteht in guten
wirtschaftlich guten zeiten sich
rücklagen zu bilden um für schlechte
zeiten vorbereitet zu sein haben wir in
einer sehr vielfältigen demokratie und
wir sind im politischen wettbewerb und
jeder möchte punkten in seiner wähler
klientel was dazu führt dass wir in
politisch in wirtschaftlich guten zeiten
das geld mit vollen händen ausgeben so
genannte soziale geschenke verteilen den
sozialstaat weiter ausbauen das darf ich
als sozialpolitikerin sagen die seit
vielen jahren in diesem bereich arbeitet
ohne wirklich tatsächlich darauf zu
schauen wie das künftige generationen zu
bezahlen haben und hier möchte ich gerne
an ein thema anknüpfen dass wir in der
runde vorher schon diskutiert haben am
ende kommt es oft dass persönliche
format von politischen
entscheidungsträgern an auch in der lage
zu sein unbequeme wahrheiten
auszusprechen den menschen auch mal zu
sagen wir können hier nicht noch eins
drauf setzen weil es wird einem am ende
sowieso nicht gedankt dann wird immer
noch mehr und immer noch mehr gefordert
und so in luthers ein verselbständigt
sich das in der politischen debatte und
insofern ist es ein einer formulierung
eines anspruches ich aber ich möchte
eine sache kurz zeigen und zwar hat
heute ja einer eine
ungebrochen eine unangenehme und ich
zeig mal das video heute von herr habeck
wir haben in deutschland eine störung
der gasversorgung so ist definiert daher
ist es erforderlich
diese alarmstufe auszurufen
gas ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland wir sind also jetzt gehalten
die gasverbraucher zu reduzieren jetzt
schon im sommer dann vor allem mit der
perspektive auf den winter
die mittel der frechheit und wissen sie
warum
im mai
2022 haben wir so viel gas wie noch nie
in der geschichte deutschlands dazu
verwendet strom zu erzeugen und man bei
der kriegs angriff im februar ganz
ehrlich wie man das machen kann verstehe
ich nicht ich dann hin zu stellen mit
einem betroffenen gesicht dann würde
wahrscheinlich kategorie fallen bei
ihnen mit nach dem motto am 1 ehrlich
nein ich glaube nicht als gutmenschen
ich wollte mich glaube ich ganz gut den
menschen auch nicht von ganz gute von
politikern er seit ihr gar nicht wieder
verrechnet
ich würde erstmal bei ihrem gesagt es
liegt an den menschen und ich bin ganz
deutlich sagen nein jedoch an
instrumenten wir haben wir könnten
doppelte buchführung einführt das ist
kompliziert für könnten die bilanz haben
des staates auf europäischer ebene würde
sogar gefordert die bundesregierungen
weigern sich eine bilanz aufzustellen
schon seit jahren meine müssten sie mich
aufweisen da könnt ihr herr heil nicht
mehr sagen und die grundrechte kosten
der fünf milliarden die kosten fünf
milliarden pro jahr wachsen über die
nächsten jahrzehnte das sind paar
hundert milliarden die da im gesetz
drinstehen nicht 5 milliarden das könnt
ihr mir war das zweite ist wir haben den
bundesrechnungshof der
bundesrechnungshof sei legt regelmäßig
die regierung und wissen was die
politiker machen gibt schöne spruch
gelesen gelacht gelocht vielen ist
überhaupt nicht ernst und die medien
lebens gar nicht auf
sie können dies ernst nimmt
bundestagsabgeordnete aber dann frage
ich sie haben sich für oder gegen wieder
aufbau von gestimmt im bundestag in der
eu
das kann ich gerade nicht sagen das ist
natürlich jetzt ganz übel dabei hab das
war etwas was wenn der
bundesrechnungshof wenn simones
rechnungshofes gutachten es ist sind
hunderte von milliarden lasten die da
eingegangen wurden dringend davor
gewarnt die politik sagt naja cukas ja
es ist das ist nur eine sache natürlich
würde ich jetzt erst mal spontan sagen
ja sie haben mit allem recht man kann
nicht rechnen es wird geld für frühstück
weil es auch zum bisher zum nulltarif
nullzinspolitik gedruckt werden konnte
ich glaube es auch ein ganz großes übel
allerdings muss ich einmal sagen nicht
so recht vergleich zur erklärung was sie
jetzt hier sehr überzeugend dargelegt
haben könnte man auch mit einem
minuszeichen von anderen
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern vorgetragen
bekommen als es gibt auch
wirtschaftswissenschaftliche genau das
gegenteil sagen beispielsweise ihr
kollege fragt stadt zum beispiel würde
jetzt hier auch auf zahlen berufen und
cam zu ganz ganz anderen ergebnis gibt
gewerkschaftsnahe
wirtschaftswissenschaftler arbeit gerne
wirtschaftsminister eines
regierungsnahen
sein aber es ist nicht ganz so eingängig
wie sie es hier darstellen was meinen
punkten wir werden die politik kann
rechnen ich würde sagen die politik ist
im spannungsfeld von unglaublich vielen
experten sie lässt sich mal von diesem
mal von jenen beraten und ganzen zu
wenig kompetenz vielleicht zu wenig
charakterbildung um zwischen diesen
experten auszulesen mal findet für das
was man will immer experten und man
findet auch immer wirtschaftsexperten
die dann war sein habig oder eine schuld
sagen also was der staat wieder gesagt
hat völliger käse hier sind die
richtigen zahlen macht weiter das wasser
so seien natürlich rechnen wir mal an es
wäre
schon der ruf der bundesrechnungshof man
ganz ehrlich ist eine institution die
heißt die geht das kaiserreich gab es
das schon das ist eine wichtige
situation der steuerzahler viel geld
dafür in holland gibt eine ähnliche
institutionen die bewertet sogar vor den
wahlen die wahlprogramme und das wird in
den torschuss mitdiskutiert machen quasi
gutachten zu dem wirtschaft gibt es eine
tolle ergebnisse bei den wahlen wenn
deutschland seine arbeitsprogramme
mitbewertet ist also ich habe alles ich
habe wahrscheinlich mit der einzige hier
am tisch der alle wahlprogramme gelesen
haben ich habe das mal podcast
besprochen die grünen zwei stunden
braucht eine gelesen mein letzten waren
sie aber auch dann wissen sie werde
gelitten das ist natürlich die dass
letztlich das wirtschaft nicht wirklich
aus zu berechnen der bundesrechnungshof
das ist dieser herr vater ist nah an der
spd ich habe kein was am hut haben
dürfen sich jetzt gemerkt weil ich dann
wäre allen enttäuschten dh es gibt
bundesrechnungshofs gibt es neutrale
instanz nie weiß aus wie vor jahren
fehlen das wäre ein maßstab den
aufzuwerten und es wäre auch ein maßstab
dass die aussage des rechnungshofs in
talkshows über egal wo sie sind auch mit
aufgenommen werden von journalisten das
andere ist eben doppelte buchführung
dass wenn dort das sind dass er heil ich
sagen kreis kostet 5 milliarden sondern
sofort satow die verbindlichkeit des
deutschen staates haben wir heute mal
gerade unter einer milliarde frösche wir
haben jetzt eigentlich gebannt zu der
hersteller doziert
sie frei schwimmen kann die politik denn
jetzt rechnen kann die politik nicht
rechnen sollte die politik vielleicht
wirklich hier als anregung unter ihrem
wagen immer einen strich machen so teuer
wird die nummer also ich gehe davon aus
dass die politik rechnen kann wir haben
viele ministerien mit vielen vielen
tausend mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern wie wir wissen und ich
denke die frage was für eine politik man
macht es am ende eine frage des
politischen willens wir haben bei
verschiedenen krisen der vergangenen
jahre fest gestellt dass wir große
entscheidungen in diesem land innerhalb
von wenigen wochen treffen können wenn
wir es wollen und insofern ist die
antwort für mich relativ klar also die
also einer der schnellen atomausstieg
ganz kurz mal einen dieser
entscheidungen diese stadt also in japan
da passiert und tsunami bei uns
passieren die so viel zu wenig und
schwuppdiwupp wird thomas enders ist wie
ein schönes beispiel für
hat eigentlich mit rationalität nichts
zu tun